east frontcourt east frontcourt which
means the captain will come from the
front court okay
this is this this to me this should be
can i announce it i'm telling who it
should be
the captain
leading vote getter in the east
kevin durant
of the brooklyn nets i mean he had a
season before they entered it that is
well deserving of that mvp leads the
league in scoring with 29 a night seven
rebounds six assists shoots 52 percent
how many 12th all-star appearance this
year in his 15th season for the
four-time scoring champion and kenny
two times
durant
so he is does this match
or do you do you want to say or you know
actually i got confused i thought you
were going to start with the backcourt
no front court would you beat the taller
problem yeah i have no problem with
kevin kevin kevin
chuck you know kevin's like he's like
the only person on that team i like yeah
let's let us let us continue
with the uh i really like kevin but
that's it with the two other oh and joe
front court starters
giannis antenna cupola oh i love him and
joelle mb oh of course the mvp this was
yeah this was uh
this was pretty clear-cut i think oh
that would be all good
giannis sixth straight all-star
appearance he's averaging 29 which is
fourth in the league
rebounds with 11
shoots 53
he's had 19 30-point games
uh
four 40-point games and three triple
doubles and joel embiid fifth straight
all-star selection in his sixth season
29 points a game that's number three
tenth and rebounds with 11.
21 games of 30 points or more six games
of 40 plus which is the most
in the nba he's the mvp in this league
and i'm gonna say it now by far by far
by far
like steps
listen no disrespect all these other
guys having some good years but that man
right there is playing better basketball
than anybody in the world we i don't i
don't disagree and you know we still
have a lot of basketball to go
but every time i look at and say he's
you know going to win it easily then out
that same night i'll turn on and i'll
see jokic with 34-21 i'll see john
morant with 38 and 12. so they're saying
yeah he's might be winning but if he
slips up in the second half of the
season we have not gone too far to win
this award he's scored 30 plus in 14 of
his last 15 games um shall we move on
yes know what this one's going to be
easy back court which which chuck
thought was coming just moments ago
this is this is going to be interesting
it's my favorite city y'all going to be
interesting i got two favorite cities
toronto and
chicago and here are your starters in
the backcourt
from the chicago bulls there we go demar
derozan oh come on from the atlanta
hawks trey young those are your
east
backcourt starters and derozan what a
season for the 30 and 17 bulls his first
all-star selection since 18 his fifth
overall
26 5-5 shooting 50 percent
12 games of at least 30 points for demar
derozan and the team that's number two
by just a hair behind miami in the
eastern conference and trae young
his fourth season his second all-star
selection
28 points a game is number five
nine assists is number three
18 30 games 45 from the floor 38
from deep
and the atlanta hawks trae young is an
all star
starter
what i'm not going to i like trey a lot
but i thought it should have been zach
levine i thought the bulls two goals i
thought two bulls i mean no disrespect
the hawks are the 12 seed but i thought
levine and demar derozan should have
been a starting back court in my opinion
i like trey not trying to hate him but
just my personal opinion i think both of
those guys either one will make it
i think if trey young wasn't on the
starting thing he would have made it and
same with zach levine he's going to make
the nba all-star game the way the
process is is who the fans yeah yeah but
in terms of fan voting of trey young is
what the fans want to see exactly 100
you know i'm just proud of my with my
boy i i forget that my boy mark eversley
works with the bulls i forget the
general imagination he came from
something i can't even pronounce it but
they've done a fabulous job i said
before this season the chicago bulls
with my surprise team and this
man they can't get a break with the
injuries
uh the injuries bug has killed them but
they still got the second best record in
the eastern conference so shout out to
the bulls for putting a great team
together and hopefully at some point
they'll get healthy
and on inside the nba tonight you guys
will have time now to formulate who you
think the reserves should be so we will
uh we'll have one question we'll go
through that yes
phoenix suns
no starters best record in the nba yeah
you know what it happened to the utah
jazz last year too devin booker
is playing great and cp3
i got a question for you kim okay that's
an mvp candidate no no
who are you taking from the miami heat
well i know again we'll get into all
that later tonight on inside the